désolé pour ce petit quart d'heure de
retard mais on a beaucoup échangé avec
Madame Duflot je pense qu'il en sera de
même avec vous donc merci d'avoir
répondu présente à notre invitation de
cette commission d'enquête sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique donc
madame de la ministre vous avez succédé
à Madame Duflot et dans l'ordre des
auditions également aujourd'hui que nous
venons donc d'auditionner vous lui avez
succédé en avril 2014 vous avez occupé
ce poste jusqu'en février 2016 date à
laquelle vous avez retrouvé votre mandat
de député de Tarn-et-Garonne avant
d'être réélu en 2017 et vous avez exercé
votre mandat de député jusqu'en 2022 je
précise que c'est aujourd'hui en votre
qualité bien sûr d'anciennes ministres
que nous vous recevons votre expérience
gouvernementale a notamment été marquée
par la préparation et le vote d'un
dispositif auquel votre nom reste
associé le dispositif Pinel relatif à
l'investissement locatif mais ce n'est
pas sur ce sujet que nous vous
questionnerons aujourd'hui mais bien sur
celui de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments sur ce sujet votre passage au
ministère a notamment été marqué par la
préparation et le vote de la loi de
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte du 17 août 2015 qui a
fixé un certain nombre d'objectifs
importants on peut par exemple citer la
cible de 500 000 rénovations de
logements par an ou encore la
suppression des passoires thermiques
avant 2025 et de leviers pour inciter à
la rénovation je pense notamment à la
mise en place du crédit d'impôt
transition énergétique le cite madame la
ministre la Commission souhaite savoir
le bilan que vous tirez de votre passage
au gouvernement quelles sont en matière
de rénovation énergétique vos principaux
motifs de satisfaction et qu'elles sont
au contraire vos regrets les sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez souhaité aller plus
loin et dans ce cas qu'elles ont pu être
les obstacles que vous avez rencontré
quel verrou avez-vous
identifié est-ce qu'un ministre de plein
exercice a été un atout ou à présenter
des difficultés pour la coordination
avec la ministre chargé de l'écologie et
de l'énergie je voudrais également vous
inviter à nous donner votre analyse des
raisons pour lesquelles les objectifs
visaient ne sont jamais atteints quel
jugement portez-vous sur la politique
menée en matière de rénovation
énergétique depuis votre départ du
gouvernement la rénovation énergétique
bute-t-elle sur des questions de
financement de réglementation de
méthodes d'inconstances ou je dirais
même et aussi sur une prise de
conscience insuffisante des enjeux
avant de vous laisser la parole pour un
propos introductif d'une quinzaine de
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat qu'elle fera l'objet
d'un compte-rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage de votre commission d'enquête
serait passible des peines prévues aux
articles 300
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc madame la ministre a prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure
voilà on va vous laisser la parole pour
une quinzaine de minutes et ensuite
monsieur le rapporteur puis un certain
nombre de nos collègues vous poseront
des questions c'est à vous merci madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs cette commission d'enquête
revêt de mon point de vue une importance
particulière puisque lorsqu'on évoque
les sujets de logement ou on évoque
tantôt le sujet du logement sous le
prisme de la de la construction tantôt
sous le prisme de la rénovation mais
sans finalement regarder l'un comment
fonctionne-t-il avec l'autre et de mon
point de vue c'est important de regarder
les choses aussi de manière
complémentaire et de ne pas opposer
comme le font peut-être certains
aujourd'hui construction rénovation en
ce qui me concerne et vous le savez
lorsque je suis arrivé en avril 2014 au
ministère du Logement j'ai souhaité
mener une action globale une action qui
s'est traduite par un plan de relance
qui a d'abord été présenté en juin et
puis compléter en août 2014 et qui avait
pour ambition justement à la fois de
traiter les sujets de construction et je
sais que c'est pas le sujet de votre
commission d'enquête et également de
porter une attention particulière à la
question de la rénovation parce que si
nous voulons aujourd'hui résorber la
crise du logement et le mal logement il
est nécessaire d'agir sur ces deux
leviers et ne pas les prendre de manière
distincte pourquoi je dis ça parce que
je comprends la cible évidemment de
votre commission d'enquête mais
lorsqu'on est en responsabilité
lorsqu'on est ministre du Logement on
doit avoir un regard global sur
l'ensemble du des segments pour
l'ensemble de la et ne pas opposer les
acteurs les uns aux autres alors je ne
reviendrai pas évidemment sur sur les
sujets construction ici mais ils sont
quand même importants pour fluidifier
les parcours résidentiels et notamment
dans les gros dans les grosses
rénovations lourdes
les sujets des copropriétés par exemple
il est important d'avoir anticipé les
capacités de relogement au préalable
donc ce plan de relance comportait deux
priorités la première la construction je
l'ai dit je n'y reviens pas et la
deuxième c'était effectivement accroître
le volume de la rénovation thermique
donc ce plan de relance a permis
d'accélérer de donner une impulsion
forte un message politique important et
notamment sur la question de la
rénovation énergétique des logements
donc un premier champ d'action de ce
plan de relance concernait le parc HLM
avec un certain nombre d'outils que nous
avons mobilisé entre l'État et la Caisse
des Dépôts grâce notamment au pré à
l'amélioration qui est un prêt
généraliste à l'écho-prés logements
social qui était dédié aux financement
de la rénovation thermique du parc de
logements sociaux qui comme vous le
savez
à besoin de rénover de nombreux
logements et aussi un prêt amiante
destiné à financer uniquement les
surcoûts liés au traitement de l'amiante
quand on procède à une rénovation
globale il incluait aussi pour la partie
HLM un accord de mutualisation conclut
avec les bailleurs sociaux qui a permis
de mettre un oeuvre un vaste plan de
rénovation des logements sociaux c'était
750 millions d'euros sur trois ans qui
ont permis de mutualiser les ressources
des bailleurs sociaux pour dégager des
capacités d'entraînement important pour
rénover le parc social
l'action c'est aussi bien sûr dirigé sur
le parc social mais ensuite sur le parc
privé
et vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente le gouvernement a initié un
ensemble d'outils permettant de mieux
informer les ménages de mieux les
accompagner dans leur projet
d'amélioration de la performance
énergétique de leur logement et c'est le
renforcement du crédit d'impôt pour la
transition énergétique en vigueur à
partir de
qu'on a annoncé en août 2014 pour
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat celui-ci a
permis de financer à hauteur de 30% des
travaux sans les conditionner à un plan
global de rénovation ce qui représentait
environ 1400 euros par contribuable en
moyenne
nous avons également renforcé le
programme Habiter mieux de la nain ces
aides ont été réhaussées le champ de ses
bénéficiaires potentiels a été élargi
cela représenté alors 45% des
propriétaires
occupants un logement de plus de 15 ans
les évolutions apportées au programme
habité mieux notamment avec les
collectivités locales avec conduit à des
objectifs ambitieux plus de 50000
logements par an le nombre de logements
financés par Lana aura été multipliée
par quatre depuis 2012
parce qu'il est essentiel de poursuivre
ce programme les ressources de l'agence
avaient été augmentés
à plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs au fil
des lois de finances pour traiter plus
de 45 000 logements en 2015 pour ce
faire le fond d'aide à la rénovation
thermique avait été renforcée le
programme Habiter mieux à pu mobiliser
annuellement plus de 250 millions
d'euros et le gouvernement avait
renforcé les crédits de la nain pour
atteindre des niveaux qui étaient très
très supérieure à ceux qui étaient le
cas les années passées alors évidemment
et vous l'avez dit aussi de telles
mesures n'ont pas eu des effets
immédiats les services
de Lana notamment n'était pas préparés à
accueillir autant de demandes mais cette
politique a voulu s'inscrire dans la
durée et je crois que là il y a une des
clés de réflexion de mon point de vue
c'est
dispositif qui doivent s'inscrire dans
le dans le temps long pour rassurer les
ménages pour donner de la prévisibilité
prévisibilité aussi pour les entreprises
parce que lorsque on
que ce soit pour le cice comme sur les
simplifications sur les cours près à
taux zéro que l'on avait aussi simplifié
c'était il y avait un critère déco
conditionnalité avec des entreprises RGE
qui pouvaient réaliser ses travaux et
donc là aussi il a fallu faire monter en
gamme les savoir-faire les compétences
certifiées labellisés un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs d'artisans et notamment
un tissu qui constitué de TPE d'artisans
donc il a fallu les entraîner pour
préparer à traiter le nombre de demandes
qu'ils avaient et ce qu'on a pu
constater c'est que la montée
en compétences c'est fait quand même
assez lentement et ça même si les
financements étaient là même si un
certain nombre de dispositifs avaient
été améliorés corrigé simplifier il y
avait aussi la filière à entraîner et à
mobiliser
donc là aussi
par rapport à ces critères là la
réactivité des entreprises n'a pas
permis cette mise en oeuvre immédiate et
ce qui a entraîné aussi on en a tous à
l'époque où vous m'aviez tous saisi pour
me faire part de retard de traitement
dans les dans les dossiers de de l'année
au-delà de ces aspects
dans le ministère du Logement et dans le
plan de relance j'avais aussi souhaité
ouvrir le prêt à taux zéro dans l'ancien
sous conditions de travaux
c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait au moins 25% de
travaux
de réaliser à l'occasion pour bénéficier
du prêt à taux zéro pourquoi parce que
dans ma vie des Luc locales je
constatais régulièrement que nous avions
en coeur de vie là de ville de village
de dans nos communes beaucoup de
logements fermés vacances qui
nécessitait effectivement des travaux
pour accueillir de déprimons accédants
et bien souvent
ils avaient tendance à aller construire
du neuf parce qu'il y avait là des
dispositifs d'accompagnement il y en
avait pas sur l'ancien alors au départ
vous en souvenez peut-être ce prêt à
taux zéro dans l'ancien a été réservé à
6000 commune alors 6000 communes c'est
exactement ce que je viens de dire c'est
pas lisible c'est pas clair
la commune X à côté de la commune y il y
avait droit et pas et pas l'autre sur
des critères sur des taux de vacances
qui étaient quand même assez proches les
uns les autres ce qui m'a amené à
corriger dans la loi de finances
suivantes ce prêt à taux zéro pour le
généraliser dans l'ancien ce qui a eu un
effet aussi à la fois
d'accompagnement des primo-accédants
pour acquérir un logement sous condition
de travaux qui pouvaient aussi se
coupler avec les autres aides que l'on
connaît ce qui a eu un impact positif
dans de nombreuses communes en termes de
d'aménagement du territoire et en termes
de rénovation des logements ou ceux qui
a permis aussi d'éviter parfois quelques
artificialisations des sols en
périphérie
pour les copropriété qui reste madame la
Présidente encore aujourd'hui
un vrai sujet à traiter
nous avions essayé de mobiliser avec la
norme
en adoptant un plan triennal pour les
copropriétés fragiles et en difficulté
parce que là on est même pas uniquement
sur de la rénovation énergétique on est
aussi dans certaines d'entre elles dans
de l'habitat insalubre dans de l'habitat
indien indigne donc on avait lancé ce
plan triennal avec Lana qui a aussi là
aussi été abondé de 60 millions d'euros
de mémoire donc il y avait quand même
des moyens pour à la fois accompagner
les collectivités locales dans le
traitement des copropriétés parce que le
déficit d'ingénierie par rapport à ce
type de problème il est il était tout à
fait considérable et dans le même temps
nous avions
créé aussi les opérations d'intérêt
général de requalification des
copropriétés dégradées nous avions lancé
la première à Clichy-sous-Bois et
d'autres préfigurations et puis depuis
il y en a d'autres qui sont qui ont
continué à sortir ce que nous voulions
avec ces hordes c'était une action
globale d'ampleur en mobilisant tous les
partenaires et je crois là qu'il y a
peut-être je ne dis pas par rapport à la
dernière question que vous m'avez posée
sur les fringues les méthodes moi je
crois que si on fait un bilan de ce qui
a marché de ce qui a pas marché et si je
prends par exemple le plan de relance de
la construction sur le neuf qui a pu
marcher c'est qu'il a été construit avec
les acteurs avec la filière avec les
collectivités locales en créant des
partenariats et je pense que il n'y a
pas qu'une recette miracle et ce n'est
pas qu'une question c'est pas qu'un
sujet qui qui à mon avis fait défaut
dans le sujet qui qui préoccupe
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas sur la
méthode essayez d'entraîner l'ensemble
de la chaîne que ce soit les
professionnels les copropriétés les
propriétaires les locataires mais aussi
les partenaires de l'État et des
collectivités locales de renforcer
l'ingénierie me paraît indispensable
pour
réussir réussir cela et puis il y a un
sujet sur les copropriétés dégradées
c'est le modèle économique aujourd'hui
les professionnels vous le disent la
rénovation est dans le contexte que nous
connaissons encore peut-être plus qu'il
y a
le les opérations d'ampleur ont un coût
dans certains territoires les
rénovations ne se traduiront pas par des
augmentations de loyer et donc il faut
là aussi peut-être d'avoir de
l'ingénierie technique c'est évident
mais aussi un modèle financier qui
permettent d'équilibrer ces opérations
et
travail sur le financement il est sur
les copropriétés en tout cas il me
semble
encore à creuser et peut-être dans le
cas de vos travaux à faire des
préconisations et des recommandations de
financement et puis moi il y a un autre
point qui me tient à cœur sur ces
questions de performance énergétique
c'est tout ce que l'on a pu faire pour
essayer de développer l'innovation parce
que si nous voulons parvenir à atteindre
des performances des des sauts entre
l'existant et la réalisation cela passe
par le développement de l'innovation
dans la filière bâtiment et nous avions
pour cela
mis en place j'avais mis en place le
plan de transition numérique pour
développer une offre de logements de
meilleure qualité à moindre coût on
avait fait un plan de recherche
développement sur l'amiante on avait
fait un programme d'action pour la
qualité de la construction et la
transition énergétique avec un partage
de une bonne pratique des guides pour
des rénovations
globales à destination des
professionnels pour promouvoir les
matériaux à faible empreintes carbone on
avait lancé un plan bois construction
également
et puis nous avions aussi mené des
programmes innovants avec les
collectivités comme par exemple
l'expérimentation centre bourg sur pour
agir sur sur la vacance et la rénovation
du bâti avec avec Lana mais c'était
aussi dans le cadre de ville de demain
avec les écoquartiers sur la capacité
d'innovation qui peut irriguer beaucoup
de secteurs le programme écosysté avec
les métropoles pour tester des solutions
innovantes sur la gestion des ressources
et des services à travers un paysa
et puis des innovations urbaines qui
avaient pu être favorisées avec les
démonstrateurs de la de la ville durable
et je crois que ces efforts sur la
recherche sur le sur les sauts
technologiques sur les matériaux sur les
matériaux biosourcés
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que depuis quelques
années c'est ces sujets là sont moins
prégnants moins visibles et c'est
regrettable parce que si on veut avoir
des process un peu industrialisés pour
réaliser de la rénovation à plus grande
échelle il faut que
il y ait des efforts de recherche et
développement sur ces matières là enfin
pour terminer vous avez posé une
question sur le fait d'être un ministère
de plein exercice si c'était une chance
ou un frein
cela ne vous surprendra pas madame la
Présidente mais je considère que c'est
un c'est une c'est un atout un atout
considérable pour peser dans les
arbitrages budgétaires
mais aussi
dans
l'exposition qu'il y a dans la prise en
compte du secteur c'est à dire que à la
fois quand on est un ministre de plein
exercice
on peut porter la parole de son
ministère directement
ce qui n'est pas le forcément le cas
lorsqu'on est ministre délégué rattaché
au ministère de l'environnement comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
et ça permet aussi d'avoir un lien très
direct avec l'ensemble des
professionnels avec l'ensemble des
filières et de pouvoir dans les dans les
moments d'échange et dans les moments de
vie gouvernementale de pouvoir
réellement porter la parole de ces
professionnels de ses acteurs des
collectivités locales aussi qui nous
remontaient un certain nombre de
difficultés pour réaliser telle ou tel
sujet et je crois que c'est un véritable
atout et puis ça montre aussi
l'importance qu'on a encore de un
secteur et j'ai l'habitude de dire que
le logement
c'est un très beau ministère évidemment
mais c'est quand même le ministère du
quotidien c'est le ministère de la vie
concrète de nos concitoyens de leur
difficulté mais aussi de leur lieu
d'épanouissement dans cela est possible
et quand on voit l'impact dans le budget
des ménages de du coût du logement mais
aujourd'hui aussi des du poids des
factures énergétiques on comprend bien
l'intérêt de votre mission dans ce
contexte d'urgence climatique d'urgence
économique d'urgence sociale également
et dans les freins que j'identifie pour
aller sur sur cette question avant d'en
terminer
moi je pense qu'il y a la méthode ce que
je vous ai dit sur la vision
partenariale il y a la question que j'ai
évoquée un peu du modèle économique
notamment pour les copropriétés
dégradées
mais il y a aussi la question du reste à
charge aujourd'hui nous avons de plus en
plus de familles monoparentales de
décohabitation
les charges du logement
c'est encore plus difficile pour une
personne seule ou une famille
monoparentale et lorsque c'est ces
familles ont envie de se lancer dans des
travaux de rénovation énergétique malgré
l'empilement des aides et parfois de
l'année cécité aussi peut-être de les
simplifier un peu pour les rendre plus
plus lisibles et plus accessible
il y a malgré tout même si on avait
essayé de recentrer les dispositifs de
la NAS sur les personnes les plus
modestes les plus fragiles je considère
que dans le contexte économique que nous
connaissons le reste à charge pour ces
personnes là restent trop lourds et donc
un frein à la rénovation de du logement
merci beaucoup pour ces propos
introductifs madame la ministre donc
maintenant on va laisser la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame l'après madame présidente
madame madame la ministre merci pour
votre intervention et votre balayage
assez large de votre de votre
intervention donc sur c'est vrai que
vous avez été entre avril 2014 et
février 2016 et en plein dans le dans la
loi 2015 relative à la transition
énergétique ou effectivement il y a eu
un certain nombre de dispositions et
d'orientation qui ont été actées à
travers cette loi et notamment sur la
question de la rénovation des
rénovations des logements du coup
j'avais plusieurs plusieurs questions il
y avait d'abord vous étiez en même temps
que que Ségolène Royal qu'on a qu'on a
auditionné donc la semaine la semaine
dernière et vous avez un petit peu
répondu mais d'avoir justement les
relations qui peut y avoir entre le
ministère de ministère de l'Écologie et
puis ministère du logement dans les
arbitrages dans les orientations est-ce
que c'était des choses voilà est-ce que
des discussions j'imagine qu'il y en a
eu mais est-ce que c'était pour vous
pour vous un frein en tout cas parce
qu'il y avait des divergences de point
de vue ça peut être intéressant qu'on
cette cet éclairage là
on vient d'avoir l'audition de ces cils
de Cécile Duflot sur donc qui était
juste juste avant vous et qui nous
disait enfin pour résumer rapidement
mais de dire en gros à partir du moment
où à la fois on a un point d'entrée
assez simple et donc on dirait un numéro
d'accès très direct un accompagnement du
coup des des personnes et puis derrière
un financement mais notamment avec du
long terme en tout cas ça fonctionne
et du coup voilà on y arrive et donc
selon vous parce que c'est vrai que si
on fait le lien jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec
des ambitions à travers les différents
textes avec les différentes politiques
qui ont été menées où on s'aperçoit que
non les objectifs on les a pas
complètement atteints en tout cas et
qu'on cherche encore justement à comment
les atteindre que ça soit en terme de de
quantité mais aussi de qualité en tout
cas vous avez parlé aussi sur le sur la
question des justement cette question du
reste à charge et de s'oriente vers les
vers les plus les plus faibles et donc
du coup de
peut-être de mieux de mieux comprendre
enfin selon vous justement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui a péché quoi
donc s'il le faut avaient l'air de dire
que c'était justement en termes de
programmation financière et de se dire
qu'à un moment donné si on n'a pas une
orientation sur du long terme sur cette
programmation financière et donc elle
nous parlait par exemple d'une loi de
programmation et que ça serait peut-être
intéressant justement d'avoir une vraie
loi de programmation qui permet
justement d'avoir ces grandes
orientations donc je voulais savoir ce
que vous en ce que vous en pensiez par
rapport à votre à votre expérience
a été abordé aussi à plusieurs reprises
dans nos auditions la question d'un
service public de la de la rénovation
qui permettait justement d'avoir un peu
de la fluidité en tout cas dans toutes
ces politiques et notamment aussi
d'avoir ce lien aussi sur les
territoires
mais avec une cohérence à l'échelle à
l'échelle nationale dont je voulais
aussi avoir cette votre retour par
rapport à par rapport à ça et puis
peut-être pour pour terminer et puis
voilà il y aura d'autres questions de la
part de mes collègues c'est vrai
justement dans la loi 2015 il y avait
l'orientation
la volonté d'aller vers du BBC une
rénovation BBC d'ici 2050
on voit qu'on en est on est loin
qu'est-ce qui enfin selon vous justement
comment se fait-il que on a toujours du
mal d'aller justement vers cette
rénovation globale quoi et que même
quand on a des politiques de rénovation
qui a de l'argent qui est mis on est
quand même pas sur une qualité de
rénovation et que on n'arrive pas à
aller jusqu'à du BBC ou très peu le
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
la source qui peut arriver même si on
peut discuter des chiffres mais en tout
cas on voit bien qu'on est très faible
sur le sur de la rénovation globale
selon vous à la qu'est-ce qui a
qu'est-ce qui peut pêcher par rapport à
par rapport aux politiques qui sont
mises en place sur cette sur cette
question là et puis peut-être une
dernière juste question c'était sur le
la mise en place de la prime rénov suite
au crédit d'impôt c'est vrai que c'est
crédit d'impôt qui était mis en place de
savoir voilà selon vous qu'est-ce que
entre ces deux dispositifs voilà un
petit peu votre recul puisque vous avez
évidemment vécu famille en place
le crédit d'impôt et voilà ce passage à
la prime rénote selon vous quel a été le
votre avis sur cette question merci
beaucoup
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
alors sur les questions
interministérielles puisque vous avez
auditionné Ségolène Royal elle a dû vous
dire que c'était elle qui pilotait le
texte
sur la croissance verte puisque c'était
elle qui était en charge de
l'environnement évidemment il y a des
discussions interministérielles sur les
mesures comme comme à chaque fois mais
je dois dire que sur sur ce sujet là les
relations se sont et les questions que
nous nous posions et notre volonté
d'accélérer de trouver
des outils simples lisibles et qui du
coup pourrait être efficace
à la fois en termes de rénovation
énergétique réalisée mais aussi par
rapport au coût pour les finances
publiques parce que c'est évidemment un
sujet qui se pose toujours lorsqu'on est
en responsabilité quelle que soit le
dispositif que l'on porte on regarde
l'efficacité du dispositif versus
dépense dépenses publiques et là je dois
dire que
je n'ai pas le sentiment que les freins
que qui ont pu
apparaître par la suite ça ne vient
encore une fois ça ne vient pas de mon
point de vue d'un problème budgétaire ça
peut être le cas dans certaines
dispositifs en matière de logement ou en
termes
de au départ en tout cas aujourd'hui les
choses peuvent être différentes mais au
départ lorsqu'on fait le cite c'est un
crédit d'impôt donc effectivement il
faut gagner l'arbitrage face à Bercy sur
la question du crédit d'impôt parce que
vous le savez la doctrine de du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
c'est de ne pas trop aimer les
et puis l'avantage du crédit d'impôt
c'est que ça touche tout le monde qu'on
soit contribuable ou pas
donc évidemment on sait pas exactement
le chiffrage donc il y a toujours une
prudence sur sur ça mais les deux
ministres que ce soit Ségolène Royal ou
moi nous étions extrêmement favorables à
la mesure parce qu'elle était visible
elle était claire et elle permettait
d'avoir un impact sur
la réalisation des travaux c'est à dire
que ça donnait aussi une activité tout
de suite aux artisans et à la filière du
bâtiment qui à cette époque là
rencontrer quand même des difficultés
assez importantes du point de vue
économique et du point de vue social
donc de ce point de vue là sur les
arbitrages
ont permis justement de de pouvoir créer
ce crédit d'impôt de pouvoir simplifier
les co-prés à taux zéro aussi parce que
quand on parle du reste à charge c'était
aussi un dispositif
utile puisque c'était un prêt pour
réaliser ses travaux sans intérêt alors
il y a quelques années c'était moins
intéressant parce que les taux
d'intérêts étaient relativement bas mais
dès qu'il remontent on voit bien
l'intérêt de l'éco-pré à taux zéro
ensuite sur les programmations ou sur
les objectifs dans une loi de
programmation effectivement ce sont
toujours des choses qui peuvent être
intéressantes de pouvoir à la fois
mettre des objectifs en quantité en
qualité de de rénovation
et en même temps les objectifs
budgétaires qui vont avec
simplement
il y a toujours un risque malgré tout
que les nouvelles assemblées
qui arrivent des tricotes les lois de
programmation intérieure
quand on prévoit un certain nombre de
dispositifs sur du long terme on voit
bien que rien n'empêche
une nouvelle majorité de de revenir en
arrière donc ça donne certains cadres ça
peut donner de la visibilité de la
prévisibilité et en cela j'y suis assez
favorable n'empêche qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent sur les mécanismes
qui fonctionnent et puis sur les coups
de balancier qui peut y avoir
sur ma sur la prime sur ma prime rénove
moi je pouvais trouver l'idée
intéressante mais ce que je constate
c'est que c'est pas simple
beaucoup
j'étais député madame la Présidente l'a
rappelé je suis en 2022 et j'ai quand
même contenu beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui sont venus frapper à ma permanence
pour
m'exposer les complexités la difficulté
le délai de versement de ma prime rénove
donc moi je suis et dans mon parcours
ministériel j'ai toujours choisi des
mesures assez pragmatiques
assez simple qui avait un effet qui
tendait à l'efficacité
et effectivement
dans
le constat que vous faites sur les
rénovations globales qui peinent à être
faite moi je pense que
c'est pas un blocage de des
propriétaires privés ou des particuliers
qui n'ont pas envie je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a pris
conscience de la réalité de l'urgence
c'est le sujet du reste à charge et de
la solvabilité
parce que quand on voit que beaucoup de
d'accompagnement dans le secteur du
logement ont été
beaucoup recentrés
beaucoup diminué dans certains secteurs
on voit bien que tout ça bout à bout ça
crée des charges supplémentaires et donc
la rénovation globale peine à être
atteinte parce que on a un sujet de
solvabilité des ménages donc la question
c'est de trouver les moyens de
l'accompagnement des dispositifs qu'il
faut peut-être adapté pour atteindre un
reste à charge beaucoup plus faible
parce que forcément avec l'augmentation
des coûts des matériaux des matériaux
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui je
pense que courbe va continuer de
descendre assez fortement dans le
contexte que nous connaissons donc si
nous voulons et je crois que c'est le
but de cette commission d'enquête c'est
pour voir aller vers de la rénovation
globale performante mais en même temps
de se de trouver des outils qui
permettent de régler cette question du
reste à charge de la donc de la
solvabilité parce que quand il y avait
les co-prés à taux zéro simplifié le
cite on arrivait quand même à et plus
les aides de la norme pour les
propriétaires les plus modestes on
arrivait quand même à avoir
un échéancier de travaux qui permettait
d'avoir une programmation peut-être plus
efficiente
sur
la cohérence nationale et sur le service
public
moi je crois qu'il y a un sujet de
d'empilement peut-être et de nécessaire
simplification parce que vous avez et
c'est très bien des collectivités
locales qui apportent leur concours pour
accompagner les ménages sur tel ou tel
aspect de la de la rénovation
thermique des logements ensuite vous
avez les A2 d'État et finalement
on s'y perd on s'y perd un peu donc
l'idée des plateformes des guichets
uniques qui étaient l'idée initiale moi
me paraît intéressante si on veut
accélérer et remplir nos objectifs de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et quand on sait l'impact bâtiment dans
dans le poids de l'émission de gaz on
peut évidemment que que se dire qu'il
faut essayer d'identifier et de lever
les freins et les verrous
l'accompagnement individuel oui mais
pour moi le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
compte tenu du volume
ça reste les copropriétés
parce que sur l'accompagnement
individuel du propriétaire
[Musique]
occupant ou du propriétaire bailleur qui
a
quelques logements
allez le l'accompagner pour réaliser les
travaux je pense que ça sera plus simple
que trouver les outils adaptés pour les
copropriétés qu'il a nécessite des
moyens financiers considérables
c'est vraiment à grande échelle et à
grande ampleur
est-ce que certains de nos collègues ont
des questions à poser à Madame la
Ministre Laurence saumon juste une
petite par rapport aux objectifs que
vous étiez fixés avec votre dispositif
quel bilan tirez-vous sur le terme de la
rénovation d'une part sur le thème de la
construction neuve et justement est-ce
que il a pas été plutôt fléché en tout
cas utiliser versus construction neuve
que sur réhabilitation rénovation
merci alors mon Dieu vous parlez du
dispositif d'investissement locatif
alors le dispositif d'investissement
locatif dit Pinel
viser clairement du neuf il y avait une
possibilité pour des rénovations
d'ampleur complète donc là effectivement
quand on refaisait tout de manière très
importante le dispositif Pinel
s'appliquer mais il était effectivement
fléchés pour de la construction de
neuves et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur
le neuf je n'ai pas fait que le
dispositif final j'ai fait le prêt à
taux zéro j'ai fait le soutien au
logement social on a fait la
simplification des normes mobilisation
du foncier public privé
mais sur la rénovation c'est ce que je
vous ai présenté sur les parties
logements sociales logement privé avec
le programme Habiter mieux notamment
puisque c'était un levier direct du
ministère du Logement
crédit d'impôt transition énergétique
éco prêt à taux zéro c'était des
dispositifs en partage
copilotés par le ministre de
l'Environnement et le ministère du
Logement
et moi j'ai enfin je suis
je considère qu'effectivement quand j'ai
voulu présenter un plan ambitieux pour
la construction neuve et la rénovation
c'est parce que ça fait partie de la de
la philosophie qui est la mienne et de
la de la volonté du gouvernement c'était
de ne pas délaisser un secteur par
rapport à un autre et parce que quand on
voyait le nombre par exemple de
demandeurs de logement sociaux qui
explosé le nombre de de personnes qui
étaient dans un logement social dans des
zones détendues qui auraient pu devenir
propriétaire et qui ne pouvait pas parce
que les outils étaient inadaptés tout
comme des propriétaires
occupants modestes qui pouvaient pas
rénover en fait moi j'ai pas essayé
d'être plus la ministre de la
Construction ou plus la ministre de la
rénovation j'ai voulu tout à la fois
donc et en agissant avec l'ensemble
alors après les les volumes de
budgétaire ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes
effectivement sur sur l'un ou sur
l'autre mais l'action elle était
volontariste et je crois aussi que c'est
l'intérêt d'avoir un ministère de plein
exercice aussi c'est d'avoir une vision
politique et de porter un message
volontariste sur tout un secteur sans
opposer les uns aux autres et en étant
complémentaire parce que l'innovation
par exemple qu'on fait pour le logement
neuf ou pour les sur les matériaux
biosourcés ou quand on veut plus de
sobriété
foncière par exemple c'est des utilités
des innovations qui sont faites parfois
pour le 9 et qui serviront ensuite pour
la rénovation et pour le développement
de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
justement est-ce que vous trouvez pas
justement qu'il faut essayer peut-être
l'adage dit qu'il trouve les trains mal
embrasse d'avoir une vision globale
est-ce que parfois il faut pas mieux
faire par secteur justement et quand on
sait 80 % des logements d'aujourd'hui
seront les logements de demain est-ce
qu'il faut pas mieux fixer je dirais des
objectifs plus ambitieux sur la
réhabilitation rénovation que sur la
construction neuve voilà c'est est-ce
que c'est pas un regret que vous pouvez
avoir en tout cas dans la politique que
vous avez menée
non moi je ne pose pas rénovation
construction mais je considère que il y
a des sujets
où on peut pas considérer contrairement
à ce que à une petite musique qui
existait déjà d'ailleurs autant où
j'étais au gouvernement que il faudrait
moins construire et qu'on peut se passer
de de construction je crois au contraire
qu'il faut réhabiliter l'acte de
construire
parce qu'on en a besoin aussi c'est à
dire que
les professionnels disent souvent que
sur les passoires énergétiques
quand on fait une rénovation lourde sur
des passoires énergétiques je vous
invite à regarder quel est le niveau de
rénovation de catégories que l'on a
d'étiquettes
auquel on parvient
c'est quand même en de ça de la
construction du standard de construction
neuve aujourd'hui donc
c'est pour ça que le sujet des
et et prégnant et difficile à traiter
parce que même si on fait une rénovation
lourde une rénovation coûteuse on
atteindra pas du à ou du B
et donc là c'est pour ça que je parlais
tout à l'heure de la de l'innovation sur
le modèle économique mais moi je pourrai
répondre à votre question
moi je crois que pour que le secteur
fonctionne nous avons certes besoin de
rénovation et parfois des rénovations
qui s'apparentent presque de la
restructuration profonde dans certaines
copro dégradés c'est c'est le cas
et que les outils des uns servent aux
autres et
dire que je peux être apparaître plus
sur la construction c'est parce que
effectivement les chiffres de la
construction à ce moment-là étaient
tellement faible que
il y a eu un effet et on retient de moi
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui
sont peut-être plus connus sur lesquels
on m'a peut-être plus entendu mais c'est
pas pour autant que j'avais délaissé
l'action sur l'autre chambre
il est vrai vous y avez fait référence
madame la ministre aujourd'hui on entend
de nouveau cette petite musique où lui
ont dit on va tout mettre sur la
rénovation et zéro construction alors
bien sûr aussi avec percute la politique
du Zéro artificialisation nette enfin
etc mais c'est un petit peu inquiétant
et moi je partage votre avis où il faut
vraiment rééquilibrer les choses certes
la rénovation énergétique doit être
vraiment une priorité nationale et
tendre vers la massification mais pour
autant il faut continuer de construire
parce que on peut pas considérer que
dans notre pays on a suffisamment de
logements aujourd'hui pour loger
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens en tout
cas au regard de leurs attentes et de
leurs besoins est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions de la part de nos collègues
moi j'aurais peut-être une question à
vous poser sur le cite et sur l'usage
des certificats d'économie d'énergie on
a souvent vu et en tout cas ils ont été
particulièrement critiqués parce que
pouvant donner lieu à des effets
d'aubaine mais surtout à des fraudes ou
à des captations est-ce que pour vous
ces dispositifs et au regard des des
fraudes potentiels est-ce que c'était
anticipables ça ou est-ce que c'est une
fois que ça a été mise en œuvre qu'on a
pu mesurer justement les effets pervers
si j'ose dire aussi
tout dispositif finit par avoir des
biais et être contourné on parlait à
l'instant du dispositif d'investissement
locatif m'a signalé un certain nombre de
contournement qui que je n'avais
évidemment pas envisagé au moment de son
élaboration
pour les cite et les certificats
d'économie d'énergie
bien sûr le voilà les fraudes ont été
démontrés donc et à tester donc on peut
pas les contester
moi je pense que en réalité
l'objectif était tel d'utiliser de
permettre son utilisation par un nombre
important d'artisans que il y a eu
quelques enfin voilà des débordements
des fraudes et voilà la nécessité
sûrement d'adapter de corriger mais
l'objectif il était vraiment que les
les dispositifs dans un but d'efficacité
jarrobons rebondir sur ce que vous avez
dit sur le sur le neuf moi je paye
effectivement je pense qu'il faut pas
opposer et qu'on a besoin on a besoin du
neuf après c'est peut-être la question
de des critères et des qu'on souhaite
obtenir sur neuf parce qu'on voit quand
même que sur le 9 on a quand même des
qualités de bâtiment en termes de
justement qui sont pas encore je suis
sur du sur du BBC et où on est encore
très géré très faible et donc auquel on
pourrait se poser des questions dans les
années à venir sur sur de la rénovation
sur des bâtiments qui sont construits
construire récemment donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut aussi se pencher sur cette
sur cette question là il y a de plutôt
exigeant et même très exigeant sur ce
qui est réalisé en neuf non moi j'avais
peut-être une question sur le sur la
certification c'est intéressant ce que
vous avez pu dire sur la question à la
fois des des filières de l'innovation
des matériaux et donc de tout ce qui est
des entreprises qui ensuite vont
réaliser ces qui vont réaliser ces
travaux sur la certification RGE je
crois que c'était 2000 2011 qui a été
quand elle a été mis en place savoir un
peu votre recul par rapport à par
rapport à ça et peut-être sur le
principe parce qu'en fait tous les tous
les pays ne fonctionnent pas forcément
de cette manière là ou en fait on part
d'un principe de dire on labellise du
coup et on estime du coup qu'une
entreprise a ses qualités et puis
ensuite bah ça suffit je dirais à
ensuite à octroyer-les en fait une fois
que les travaux sont réalisés mais en
fait on n'a pas de
on n'a pas de contrôle après sur la
réalisation quoi et d'autres d'autres
pays ils sont pas sur cette labilisation
des entreprises mais plutôt de se dire
voilà on doit avoir du résultat et si la
réalisation est bien faite gérer quel
que soit le
labellisation de l'entreprise c'est ce
qu'on souhaite donc je voulais avoir un
petit peu votre votre avis et votre
retour par rapport à ça
effectivement sur le label RGE
on a connu une montée en puissance très
lente très
rythme mesuré
et je crois que enfin le phénomène c'est
intensifié à partir du moment où il y a
eu les l'écho conditionnalités ou et
pour autant on avait quand même fait un
travail extrêmement important très
soutenu avec la CAPEB la FFB pour
essayer de d'inciter pour former
davantage de d'artisans de TPE au
label dans les questions de
simplification de l'écho PTZ ou aussi
dans les dans les sociétés de tir
financement la question
du tiers certificateur avait été aussi
abordé
effectivement tous les modèles ne se
valent pas
et je pense là encore que il y a
peut-être certains artisans mais de
manière minoritaire et qui ont fait ces
formations là pour pouvoir réaliser ces
travaux
mais je pense que là aussi les mesures
qu'on avait mises en place à côté de la
certification le programme pacte que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le plan
numérique ça nous permettait quand même
de faire une mobilisation de la de la
filière j'avais lancé un tour de France
de la construction et de la rénovation
pour justement présenter les dispositifs
qui existaient dans toutes les régions
de France
pour justement que ces outils parce que
encore une fois là je vous l'ai dit je
ne crois pas que ça soit comme problème
budgétaire c'était aussi un problème de
connaissance et de d'appropriation pour
que l'ensemble des partenaires puissent
être là et connaissent bien les les
dispositifs
après moi je pense que si on se rend
compte que sur le le label RGE peut être
un
frein il peut y avoir d'autres
dispositifs mais sauf que faut faire
attention au menton des travaux parce
que si vous faites appel à un tiers
certificateur par exemple si on remet en
cause le principe tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui et que vous vous fassiez
venir un tiers certificateur avec la
facturation qui peut être la sienne sur
un crédit d'impôt ou une prime rénov qui
est de montant assez faible ça va être
aussi assez dissuasif donc nous on avait
préféré le choix du RGE avec les
co-conditionnalités en espérant cette
montée à compétence et en l'accompagnant
d'autres plans pour que justement le
travail que nous faisons
qui continuent à se poursuivre notamment
sur la sur les actes de construire sur
la déco décarbonations de la filière
avec
de certains matériaux plus plus
biosourcés ou plus performants puissent
irriguer l'ensemble de la fière parce
que l'artisan il est tantôt dans une
opération de rénovation il peut être
aussi demain dans une opération de
construction et donc les les process qui
l'utilisent dans la construction neuve
peuvent avoir une passerelle
intéressante pour la rénovation quand on
voit par exemple la porte du BIM
aujourd'hui
l'apport des cahiers de chantier
numérique de certains matériaux qui
étaient finalement assez peu développés
il y a quelques années et qui ont pris
beaucoup plus d'ampleur aujourd'hui on
voit bien que la filière dans sa
globalité il y a peut-être un corps ici
où là certains membres de réticences et
de freins mais à bien compris qu'il y
avait des impacts de sobriété foncière
des impacts de décarbonation de
construction plus performantes et de
rénovation plus performante
merci beaucoup je suis désolé j'en perds
merci madame la ministre et puis on vous
souhaite une bonne fin d'après-midi